>> Well Dawn, thanks
for joining us today.
It's great to have you out for
your MSR AI Distinguished
Lecture which you just gave.
Now in a smaller room
by a fire here we
can talk a bit more
personally about your career
and your current role.
What's your current
position and how
would you describe
what you do daily?
>> At Uber I'm leading
data science for maps.
So that's all of your experience
as a writer of the map,
from the time when you open
up the app all the way to
the time when you get to
your destination and
get out of the car.
Similarly on the driver side,
turn by turn navigation
for drivers for example.
So every aspect of the map
that's rider facing and that's
driver facing is part
of this mapping system,
but then also some things
that may not be as obvious.
For example, the
mapping system predicts
the travel time for drivers
from point A to Point
B for any A and B,
and that's used when you
request a ride as a rider
we look at the different cars
that are available and see
how long would it take
that driver to reach you.
So predicting that travel
time in the road network is
a really important output of
our mapping system that
may not be as visible.
>> It is cool. Just now during
the talk you just gave,
you talked about how it's
not just machine learning,
it's not just prediction.
But the job you're in right now I
would say at one of the most
well-known and premier
companies tryiong
to do its work to master
the shared economy comes at
the intersection of economics and
statistics and
logistics optimization.
So many different fields are
coming together for you.
>> Yeah, that's right. It's
an exciting opportunity to
use my interest in
statistics and machine
learning and optimization.
Economics is a new field
for me in terms
of economic models that
are important in pricing.
So, it's been really fun
to learn from some of
the top economists in the field
who have joined the team.
>> You came to Uber
after a trajectory of going
from high school to Stanford
chemical engineering is it?
It's a Math degree,
Math and CS, and then off
to Duke to do statistics,
then to Cornell as a professor,
and then through
Microsoft Research visiting
us and working with us
on predictive models
for traffic among other things,
to now in this incredible
position where you're bringing
together many of the pieces
and experiences you've had.
Now probably as a professor,
given what you've seen going
on in your daily life,
the kind of job that
you have at Uber,
and the people you work with,
what's the future curriculum for
students to master this world?
>> So, I absolutely think
that training students
in being data
driven and driving decisions
through insights from data
is a critical skill set,
the most critical skill set
that I look for when
I'm making a hire.
So in addition to
being able to build a
machine learning model,
this individual needs to be
able to engage with data,
they need to love data,
they need to when
they go to make
a decision their instinct
should be to look at
the data first and
understand what's going well
and what's going wrong.
It's a difficult skill
to teach but
I think more hands on analysis
which is neglected a bit in
courses even these days
because I think it takes more
time from the professors.
So lots of hands
on data analysis.
Data analysis using some of
these very large scale
industrial data sets
that are now available
in the public sphere,
more coding for example.
>> Per your talk you just
gave to the larger audience,
you mentioned and showed
these pieces coming together
in interesting novel ways.
Economics, optimization,
prediction.
Is there a new kind of
core coursework that's needed.
It seemed like it goes
on beyond data science.
It could be something
about that might
resonate deeply with
companies like Uber and
other companies coming to
the fore that need skills,
you might say, applied
across disciplines jointly at
the same time to solve problems.
>> Right. Well it is important
for students to come in with
a basic foundation in
these different areas.
My undergraduate degree was
great for this because we learned
some economics and
some optimization
and some statistics and
some machine learning,
so I would say that
that's very important,
just a basic understanding
of these different areas.
But we really don't expect
anybody to be coming in
with being an expert in all
four or even two of those.
Instead we pull together
teams who are people who have
a broad set with a little bit of
understanding and then
a lot of depth in one area.
We create these
diverse teams with
different specialties and
then we try to get them to
talk to each other and
to talk a language that
the other person can understand
and to bounce ideas
off of each other.
This is how we get
the best decisions at
the end of the day.
>> I was looking at
your previous history
and we've chatted in
the past about
your career and so on.
I'm just curious. How
did you get involved in
just doing a Math major,
Math and CS at Stanford?
When you were in high school did
you always know you
liked math? How'd that?
>> I always loved math.
>> Yeah.
>> Actually it was
an internship at Rockwell
scientific where I was
doing machine learning
research in undergraduate
that got me inspired.
So actually at that
time I was a major
in Chemical Engineering and after
the internship I
decided to switch to
Math and Comp Sci as a focus.
Eventually that took me to
getting a PhD in Statistics
and continuing in
the field and circling
back into Tech and Data
Science these days.
It all started back in
an internship with with what was
a Machine Learning Lab
for defense contractors.
>> Ruppel Science
Center in Palo Alto.
>> That's right. That's right.
>> I knew the place
very well doing
my graduate work at Stanford.
Who'd you work with there?
>> Mark Piot.
>> Oh fabulous. Well
he's a mutual friend
and I worked very
closele with him as well
for a number of years
when I was down at
Stanford Graduate School.
What did you do at
Ruppel Science Center?
Do you remember?
>> I was creating
systems for training and
inference in Basian networks
that could be used for a variety
of different purposes.
They had a lot of
different contracts
at the time for different
military applications, yeah.
>> It wasn't all military.
They had the space shuttle,
they had a bunch of other
things. It was great.
They set up shop right near
Stanford campus and a number
of us used to stop by there and
get a taste of this other world.
There was a big rise of
interest in those days as I
recall in decision theory and
decision making and
the uncertainty.
That's great. So that
moved you over to
math and you probably saw
some real world aspects of it.
>> That's right.
>> Then when you were getting
ready for grad school,
what was your decision
making like?
>> So actually I had
a decision to make between
going to graduate school in
Statistics and doing it
in Computer Science.
I had done a couple
of internships at
that point when I was
making the decision of
an internship with
Moises Goldschmidt
after the internship
at Ruppel Scientific,
Moises was of course a researcher
at MSR in later years.
But in the end
it was six in one and
half dozen the other.
There was a lot of
great work going on
in Artificial Intelligence
and Machine Learning
at the time and
also I wanted to
understand some of
the foundations of statistical
learning that had been
developed over
the previous 150 years.
So I ultimately decided
to get a statistics PhD.
>> It's great foundations.
>> Yeah, absolutely. It's
important to understand.
I think sometimes in
machine learning we
reinvent some of the concepts
that were learned early on,
but it's also true that
the machine learning field
has done, I would say,
a much better job of being
ambitious in terms of
its problem choice.
I think statistics is a little
bit more conservative as
a community and wants
to really ground the assumptions
that statisticians are making in
their models and make sure
that they want to be really
careful about the assumptions,
whereas machine
learning researchers
are often more ambitious
about the difficulty and
complexity of
the problems they tackle.
So the statistics community
and the machine learning
community really
have a lot to teach each other.
>> Well it comes down
to choice of problems,
aesthetics but it really is
all statistics, as we know.
>> I'm glad you feel that way.
>> So this area that you are now.
So I'm just going
to jump into Uber
because I think it's a really
interesting topic Kerry,
this whole idea of
the sharing economy and
scale and the ability to
collect all this data,
most hopefully which is
anonymized typically.
But still, the opportunity to
do optimization and prediction.
It's such an exciting world.
I want to hear your sense
for jumping into
the Uber world from
your university position.
>> Right. Well
the most amazing thing,
what is being able to
go from an idea to
deployment of that idea
in a couple of months.
And so getting really fast
feedback about how well
an idea works in practice
at very large scale.
And of course in academia,
you have much more
time to develop
the algorithms and to go very,
very in-depth on
a particular problem space,
but the timescales for
deployment and getting
feedback about how
well your systems are
working are much longer.
So, that was very exciting
for me coming into
tech and of course since
I'm leading a team,
there's those individuals are
working across a variety
of different spaces
within maps and
market place at Uber,
and each of those individuals
is developing and
deploying algorithms.
And so, just to see
us move as a team
so quickly and to learn from
that and to understand
what types of
algorithms work well in
particular situations
is really exciting.
It's expansive too because,
as I mentioned in the talk,
we pull algorithms from
a variety of different areas
economic models,
optimization model, statistics,
and machine learning
and for example,
if you look at
the the pricing space,
there's literature on
pricing both coming from
the optimization literature and
coming from the
economic literature.
And so, we hired some economists
and hired some people
from operations research,
and we put them on
the same team and people
were just coming up with ideas
and trying them and
seeing which worked best.
Of course with
safeguards in place.
>> I really think you know how
lucky Uber is to have
someone like you.
You know, I've looked at
your work over the years
and I was like, "Wow.
She's been working on
optimizing where ambulances
sit in a city to
minimize their time
to transport
potential accidents to
the right hospitals using
prediction times and
urgencies of various kinds."
You know, kind of interesting
important societal project.
You wouldn't think
it's like, you know,
mainstream necessarily,
it's very important.
And all of a sudden,
you're in this new world.
You know, you were
doing that work before
Uber even existed, right.
And here you are, someone's
looking at your resume saying,
"Oh my god. This is
what we need for Uber."
>> Yeah.
>> Something very related.
So, it's interesting.
>> Is incredibly closely related.
These challenges around
an ambulance context-
>> Describe that problem
a little bit.
>> Sure. So, one of the problems
that I worked on at
Cornell was about optimization of
location and relocation
for ambulance algorithms.
So, if you have 10 ambulances
in a city at a given time,
where should you locate them
so that they can maximize
the probability of reaching
a potential emergency in time.
Okay? Meaning before the person
has severe detrimental
health impact.
So, there's some sophisticated
optimization algorithms
for ambulances for
these location problems
and that requires inputs,
which is the prediction
of where and when
these emergencies are
going to take place.
And you can see
the direct parallels with
the ride sharing context in
which you have these drivers
and the road network,
you have instances of demand
where riders want to be
transported from
one location to another.
The ride hailing context
is more complicated
than the ambulance context not
only because of the scale,
and I think at one point I
calculated the
difference in scale,
ten to the four factor.
>> But that's good news
for injuries.
>> Good news for injury.
But also the fact that
drivers of course have
the ability to decide where
and when they want to drive,
which is different from the
ambulance context in which we
can tell that to the ambulance
drivers where to locate.
>> Interesting. If I
open up my Uber app and I see
a red cross Uber emergency,
I'll know where that idea
came from the future.
Kidding about that. So, what was
the most surprising thing
that you've noted in
your your career at Uber?
What's come up that just
kind of didn't expect or
interesting or surprising?
About the role.
>> The most surprising thing
about the role. Yeah,
that's interesting.
Well, when I came to
Uber I didn't expect
to be leading
a large team actually.
That was a bit of
a surprise, and-
>> How did that happen?
>> -definitely a change.
>> Just showed up and they?
>> I was planning on doing
an individual contributor
role on the team
and I was talking to Travis,
the CEO at the time,
and it turned out that
there was a need for
a broader management
role and he asked
me and and if there's
one principle in my career it's,
if somebody asked you to
do something that
you think is far
beyond your capabilities,
say yes anyway.
So, I just jumped in
and learned as I went.
>> That's probably
a really good your heuristic.
Except if it gets to the
administrative you
want to say no quickly
and figure out what
level you want to be
at in an organization.
It's interesting to
think about this.
Do you see yourself staying in
the industry for a while or
heading back to academia.
How will you weigh that decision
over time do you think?
I don't want an exact
answer right now,
but will you just have a process?
>> Yeah. I really love
what I'm doing right now.
I love the impact.
I love the immediacy
of the impact,
I really enjoy the teams
that I'm working with,
and the ability to hire
this incredible talent
and economics and optimization
and to be able to learn
from these people.
So, I love what I'm doing. I
don't have any plans to go
back to academia in
the near future.
Maybe way down the line.
>> Those unfortunate Cornell
students who don't have
their teacher and mentor.
Interesting. Do you have
reflections as about your time
at Microsoft Research.
You were here for a year and
a year before that as well.
You worked on
some pretty wild things.
you worked on
data center, forecasting,
forecasting crises
in data centers.
Any reflections about that work?
>> About the data center work?
>> Yeah.
>> That's interesting, yeah.
I would have loved to have seen
how well it worked in practice.
I think that this area of
analytics for decisions.
>> Let's back up. So
what were you doing?
>> Oh sure, sure. So,
the problem there was,
you have a distributed large
scale distributed system,
a data center,
and these data centers
are instrumented.
We know for each of the servers
in the data center,
we have information about
a variety of metrics like
CPU usage and memory
utilization and so on and so,
you have a lot of data
coming out of the system and
sometimes the data centers
don't hit their SLA,
something goes wrong, and
you have to figure out what
happened and do something
about it very, very quickly.
So you have these
performance crises
in the data center
and so diagnosing
what went wrong is
an important challenge.
We created an algorithm for
automatically detecting
previous crises that looked
very similar to what's
going on right now,
and if you had gone back and
diagnosed exactly what the cause
of that previous crisis was,
then you know what's
going on right
now and you can do
that in a matter of
minutes and then decide what
the appropriate intervention is.
>> So, something that I wrestle
with all the time which
is work life balance.
Given how passionate I
tend to be about everything
going on and I want to get
so much done and
there's so many fun
and interesting projects.
I can choose to go deep
on that just a few or
one or pop up and do
a few things at once,
but then there's family
and kids, relationships.
What's your sense
for how you master
work life balance and
how is it for you these
days at such a fast
paced company like Uber.
>> Right, right. I actually
find that downtime has become
more important in
my current role than
it was in my previous roles.
So, the experience
of management is so
much around being in
the right headspace when you're
interacting with that person.
So much around inspiring people,
engaging people,
helping people to thrive and
so the time that I spend
with with my friends and with
my family is incredibly
important to being in
that right headspace.
So actually, I've moved
to a much more balanced approach
since coming to Uber,
and I think it's really
benefited my management.
>> It sounds like
it's very mindful
as opposed to organic.
You actually have a plan
to approach that.
I think that's what
you're saying.
It's probably something
that I need to take
some advice from you
about this sometimes.
>> Well, it's so
important to be in
a positive headspace whenever
we're having critical and
difficult conversations
in some cases, right.
And so, you have to
build up this reservoir
of that positivity
and it's also interesting that
in other aspects
of life I think I
learned lessons and bring
them back to my work.
At one point I was,
I had a hobby,
I was playing electric bass and I
felt like some of the
things that I learned-
>> I had no idea.
>> -trying to. Oh,
that was a long time.
>> Why bass?
>> Why electric bass?
I just love it.
It sounds amazing and besides
everybody needs a bassist.
They don't necessarily need,
everybody wants to
play the guitar,
play the drums.
Not that many people want to
play the bass.
Everybody need this.
>> I love the bass
too and that's one of
my dreams is taking off
time to learn the bass.
>> Oh really? Incredible.
>> That's why I asked
you that question.
>> Yeah. But there's a kind
of things that I
learned from playing
the bass that I've taken
back to how I interact.
>> Was this in a band? Were
you actually in a band?
>> Oh my gosh, this is
a long story. I don't know.
Okay. I did briefly play in
a church band in
North Carolina. Yeah.
>> Oh, my God, that sounds
like serious bass duty.
>> It was a lot of fun.
There was a lesson
there that I learned
around what's called
staying in the pocket.
Okay. So as a musician
and playing the bass it's
really important to be
consistent and to
be steady and to
always be that person
that people can rely on.
You don't go and play
some crazy bass line in
the middle of a song.
That's not your job, right.
So that's called
staying in the pocket.
And that lesson is so
important in life and
in work I think,
staying in the pocket.
So just being incredibly
mindful of what is my role in
this particular interaction and
not going outside of that.
>> That's really interesting.
I'm thinking about whether or not
you were the kind of
person that tended to
stay in the pocket
before you learned
about this metaphor or it has
actually helped you to deal
with making sure that
you were a little bit
more gentle with people.
>> Yes. I think that
that's the case,
that I'm not naturally a person
who listens first and thinks
carefully about that.
I tend to get excited and
want to get engaged
with a response.
But really stepping back and
understanding what my role
is in this situation
is really important.
>> So let me ask you a quick
question given what you've
seen at Uber from the inside.
>> Yeah.
>> It's the personal car
going to go away?
>> Is the personal car
Not in the immediate future.
>> Let's go 15, 20 years out.
>> Fifteen, 20 years out.
I think that's
definitely the vision.
I think it's, and you already
start seeing this where
in the high density
urban cores people
are deciding to rely
heavily on a combination
of ride hailing services,
the bike share services,
and public transit.
Now that all these options
are available,
people in urban cores at least
are much more than previously
deciding not to buy that car.
And I think we will
see this evolution.
It's a slow one because in order
to move over to that world,
there's all these corner cases
that you have to solve for.
For example you have to make sure
that when you have a small child,
that there is a
transportation option that
involves a child seat.
And the ride hailing services
just haven't nailed
that particular aspect, right.
So then what you
end up happening,
at least what I imagine
happens, is that somebody,
even if they didn't decide
to own a car before,
when they have
a kid and they need
that child seat then
they buy that car at
that point, right.
And then you have the car,
once you have the car,
then you're not utilizing the
ride hailing services that much.
So in order to really
move into that world,
we really have to provide
services that fill all
of these people's needs.
Needs at all stages of life.
And also to really leverage
these multi-modal transit,
that combination,
in order to create a really
price effective solution
we're looking towards
a combination not just
of vehicular motor vehicle
transport but also the
combination with bike
sharing and with
facilitating connection to
public transit and so on.
>> I have to say that one of
my long term predictions that
I've made about the future of
technology is that within
20 years at least one
major city will close
some significant part of
inner core to
human driven vehicles.
And it'll just be all
public micro transit,
very high speed coordinated
transit that will then
become a demonstration for
the rest of the world.
I've just had that reflection
that I can see that coming.
>> That's interesting.
But don't you think
it will be a combination
of companies
providing services and
centralized infrastructure?
>> I'm not sure. It could be
one company or a city
that just invests in
public micro transit,
I can use that phrase.
These three door
special little pod vehicles
that come and go really
quickly that are interleaving.
No traffic lights because of
a coordinated inner city.
And if you need to drive in
as a human being you'll get
a permit and you'll get
a little special beacon on
your car and all
the cars will part
as you come driving in with
your human driven vehicle.
But we'll see how
the future goes.
Do you have any other kind of
predictions you
want to make about
the shared economy
and optimization
logistics economics coming
together even beyond
transportation?
>> Beyond transportation?
Well I thought
a lot about the
transportation space.
>> Stay there then.
>> Yes sure. I think there's
these interacting revolutions
going on in transportation.
And one way of summarizing
this is the acronym ACES.
So automation, like
automated vehicles,
connectivity, so the vehicles
talking to each other and to
the network, electrification,
and sharing.
If you look at the efficiency
of the ownership of a private car
when individuals
own a private car
on average they're only
using that car a couple of
percentage of the time,
two, three percent of the time.
And so, extremely
inefficient use of
the vehicle and there's
a lot of resources that go
into creating that vehicle.
And if you look at utilization
of the roadways is also
quite low because
the traffic congestion patterns
cause inefficiencies,
like the waves in
traffic cause inefficiencies.
And so if you look at
these four revolutions
in transportation,
they really build on one
another and together
could create a much
more efficient picture.
So, for example, the connectivity
could help with these waves
and traffic that you see.
If the cars are both
automated and connected,
then that means
that you could have
the closer spacing
between the cars
like you were talking about
and you could avoid
these waves in traffic.
The waves in traffic are
caused by human behavior.
>> So you see
such an inspired person.
Who are the mentors in
your life? Who's inspired you?
>> I would call it two
particular people.
One is that I mentioned before,
there was Moises Goldschmidt
has help me throughout my career.
So as a professional mentor
he's been incredibly important,
and I think I counted
up the number of jobs
that he's gotten me at
various times, three.
I think he's gotten
three different jobs
and six job offers.
>> He's a good friend. Call
out to Moises Goldschmidt.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
But if we look on
the personal side,
I would say that my mom is
an incredible inspiration.
She was way ahead of her time
because she got her PhD at
Stanford in demography
in the late 1960s.
She was one of the few women
who was doing that at the time.
And the attitudes towards women
in academia were totally
different at that point.
So she was interested in going
into an academic career.
Afterwards, she asked
the head of her department,
so when she was graduating
she asked the head of
her department for
a reference letter.
And she was pregnant
at the time and he refused
because she was pregnant.
So it just goes
to show that the attitudes
have changed so much.
>> That doesn't
really compute to me.
It's interesting.
>> But she thrived nonetheless.
>> What did she go off to do?
>> So she did a postdoc
at the East-West Center
in Hawaii, again,
studying demography.
She later went on to lead
the international branch of
the Census Bureau in
the U.S. government
for a decade or more.
She was a professor at
Hong Kong University of Science
and Technology for
a period of time.
Done incredible things throughout
her career, very groundbreaking.
So she was always
a person that you
couldn't tell her
what she couldn't do,
she was going to go out
and prove otherwise.
>> You've inherited
some of that phenotype
and genotype probably?
>> Yeah, well I hope that I have.
>> Well that's great to
hear about your mom.
It's fabulous that when you have
a parent that's so inspired.
>> Yeah that's incredible.
>> It's great. Well thanks
so much for coming in.
It's great seeing you again.
>> It's great to see you again.